en terreno neutral suiza en este
edificio el joven asesor estadounidense
jack sullivan se reúne con yankee en sí
uno de los veteranos de la diplomacia
china en la agenda las crecientes
tensiones entre china y taiwán el tono
de la disputa es tan elevado que se les
ha invitado a la cumbre de la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo en parís donde antony blinken
está de visita
estamos muy preocupados por las
actividades militares provocadoras de
china acerca de taiwán sería un error de
cálculo porque podría socavar la paz y
la estabilidad en la región por lo tanto
instamos encarecidamente a beijing a que
ponga fin a sus presiones y coacciones
militares diplomáticas y económicas
contra taiwán
según taipei las tensiones militares
están en su nivel más alto en 40 años en
pocos meses beijing ha aumentado sus
incursiones de la zona de defensa aérea
de taiwán aviones de combate bombarderos
h6 con capacidad nuclear un total de 150
aviones han sido detectados desde el 1
de octubre
la isla teme por su autonomía
democrática y se prepara para un
conflicto
si quieren atacar a taiwán y ya tienen
la capacidad de hacerlo todavía tenemos
que ver cómo se resuelve no estamos
cometiendo ninguna provocación pero si
les volvemos locos igual que ellos si
nos hacen enfadar entonces les
mostraremos también nuestras capacidades
según taipei y el gigante asiático
podría lanzar una invasión a gran escala
en 2025 ya que beijing siempre ha
considerado a taiwán como su provincia
rebelde para ser alineados por la fuerza
si fuera necesario en medio de eeuu
parece estar jugando a ambos lados de la
valla gracias a la acción de taiwán y
con beijing se compromete a no
establecer relaciones diplomáticas con
taipei en taiwán washington promete
seguir ayudándoles a defenderse la
semana pasada el presidente chino xi
jinping calificó de inevitable la toma
de posesión de taiwán